i'm keen to talk about your pitch to be
the leader of the labour party but i
thought we should just first start with
the reshuffle
that happened this week the chancellor
of course quit what did you make of it
all
well just as the labour party is
beginning to rebuild we see the same old
divisions in the
tory party and dominic cummings is just
getting more and more power
and i know boris johnson doesn't much
like coming to parliament he does at
least come for pmq's
i think we're going to have to have dc
cues for doc for dominate comings before
too long because
he's actually holding all the power and
how do we hold him accountable
i mean you say of course that dominic
cummings is holding the power there but
of course they can do what they want
because of that election result which
makes me feel we should really sort of
focus on
your pitch to be the labour leader now
now you of course are the front runner
in the race you're winning no vote has
been cast
it's really important we're we're very
disciplined and professional in this
campaign
we're trying to win every vote and we're
we're absolutely conscious that nobody's
actually made their mind up yet
but at the same time you've won clps
you've won
mps you've won unions from across the
spectrum of the party
many people are still a bit unclear
though as to what your politics
are i mean who is the real cursed just
on that
collection of um constituencies that
have supported me et cetera
what i've been trying to show in this
campaign
is that i can unite our party and that
people will support me from across
different parts of the united kingdom
but also different parts of the party
and so the one thing i've been very very
pleased about with the constituency
support is
it's from across you know all parts of
the country
particularly places that voted both
leave and remain north and south so i've
been very very pleased because
that the theme running through this for
me is unity
if we can't unite our party stop taking
lumps out of each other
then we're not going to win the next
general election so i want to bring our
party together we've got 580 000 members
that's an incredible
fighting force but only if we're united
i mean you're talking a lot about
unifying the party about unity
and but many people are trying to work
out where you
stand who you are so people stay your
centrist others say you're a left winger
i mean
are you closer to jeremy corbyn or tony
blair well at the moment what i'm trying
to do is unify
the party and i what's really
interesting is they have to know who you
are
i'll absolutely answer that but just
what is really interesting in this is
i feel a yearning in our members to turn
a page and to unify
there's a real spirit out there of
people saying yes we know what we've now
got to do
um and we could be a very very powerful
force
now yeah i'm often challenged you are
are you
you know a blair right a corbin easter
et cetera et cetera and i've always
answered that in the same way which is
say i don't need
somebody else's name tattooed on my head
to make a decision or hug a historical
figure
my message to our members is very
straightforward which is
the next stage of the journey between
now the next election
is for us just past labour governments
have come about because
members and leaders and mps have come
together and said we need to do the
thinking
about what needs to happen to get into
power leaders have done it in the past
and we need to do it again so the next
stage of the journey is for us we can't
hug other people in this
okay so are you on the left or the right
of the party then ask another way
what i want is what matters and what i
want is fundamental change
in this country i see ingrained
inequality
and only radical changes will do
anything about it
and so i do want a fundamental shift of
power of wealth
and opportunity now where other people
badge that
doesn't particularly concern me what i'm
focused on is what is
what is what are we up against here
what's the nature of the challenge and
after 10 years of austerity
we can see this inequality everywhere
and in that election we've just had
we've lost it of course but i went
across 44 constituencies
and everywhere people wanted change
people don't like the fact that we've
got homelessness
people don't like the fact that mental
health assessments take 18 months
people are not enjoying this inequality
and they want something done about it
they wanted change but they they lost
faith in the labour party as the party
that could deliver that change and we
need to
restore that faith or trust so would
jeremy corbyn have a place in your
shadow cabinet then richard
answer the question the these questions
we get about who'd be in the show
i am focused on winning this race i'm
not going to be presumptuous about what
might happen
afterwards i'm very good friends with uh
jeremy spent a lot of time
with him in the last three and a half
years he's a friend and he's a colleague
and i respect what he's done for our
party
leads through very difficult times but
um you know
i just want to stay disciplined and
professional about
what needs to happen next and that is
that this campaign which is a very
positive campaign i'm running
um needs to succeed and then we take the
decisions thereafter i'll ask you about
a couple of policies then
just trying to get a bit of a sense on
where you are on some of these kind of
big issues
at what stage do you think people should
start paying the top rate of tax the 50p
rate
well i think it should be the top five
percent i think
the broad principle that those that earn
more should pay for is
more is right but i've also set out at
some stage do you think people should
start paying the top rate but just
i've said that as a broad proposal the
top five percent but i've also said
corporation tax needs
tax needs to go back to where it was
under the last labour government
and very very importantly this is
probably the biggest thing
that tax avoidance needs to be tackled
amazon had
revenue of i think last year 10.9
billion pounds
and paid two percent tax that tax gap
has to be closed
so the top five percent should pay for
the 50p rate
that's not what you're saying is that no
no not from that start so
so what stage should people pay the top
rate well i think it should
i mean last time we said about 80 000
pounds but i'm not going to get drawn
into questions that are really for the
next manifesto what i'm setting out
abroad principles here which is
broadly speaking the top five percent
should pay more most people believe in
that principle i think
that corporation tax should go up back
to where it was under the last labour
government
and and tax avoidance has got to be
tackled this huge tax avoidance that tax
gap is
is massive on immigration yeah
in october 2016 you said this and i
think it should be reduced
uh we have to be open to adjustments of
the freedom of movement rules
do you still think that immigration
should be reduced in 2016
i was talking about skills and
immigration i was
very struck i was then shadow
immigration secretary
i was very struck around the country by
the number of businesses that were
saying to me
we can't get the skills we need that is
why we recruit from abroad
i think that's a massive problem that we
needed to address
as we leave the eu obviously things are
now going to change
i want people in this country to be able
to work in europe
i want people who are in europe to come
and work in this country i want people
should immigration be reduced
well i don't believe in numbers and i
don't believe in salary gaps
we've been playing the numbers game for
the best part of 10 years and it doesn't
work
i want people to be able to work in
europe people in europe be able to work
here i want families to be able to live
together and i absolutely want people
who want to study in europe
to be able to do so and people in europe
come and study here these are valuable
things that we should make a positive
case for because
i'm trying to kind of get a sense of you
know who you are what the pitch is you
you won't say whether you're closer to
blair or corbyn you won't say whether
you think immigration should go up or
down you won't give me specifics on your
taxes i mean you say you want to unify
the party well
some would think that you're trying to
not alienate anyone anyone in your party
to make sure you win this so be fair to
me
what i'm saying is i'm not going to hug
somebody else i can think for myself
i don't need to hug jeremy corbyn i
don't need to hug
tony blair or anybody else to make a
decision i'll make my own decisions with
my own team
over the next four years if i'm leading
the labour party in my own way
i want us to be radical we do have to be
radical
i've set out the principles of tax those
in the top five percent pay more
corporation tax to go back near where it
was under the last labour government
and to close that tax gap so i'm giving
you substantive answers
but i'm not going to play this game of
hugging
another individual to i don't need that
to make my mind out
i'll have a team of my own working
alongside me and we will craft what's
necessary for the next four years
to take us from where we are now back
into power okay
um on brexit yeah you've just suffered
the worst defeat in an election since
1935 for the labour party
and many people in your party think that
a big reason for that or perhaps the
biggest reason
is the position on brexit now of course
you as shadow brexit secretary was the
architect
of that position do you take
responsibility for it well i think we
all take responsibility for that
devastating election loss of course we
do because for millions of people who
desperately needed change
we've put them in a position where they
won't have that change
i went out with many many teams in the
election campaign
and the talk in the teams was always
what's coming up on the doors what are
people saying and there were a number of
things
people brought up the leadership of the
labor party fairly or unfairly
they brought up brexit in different ways
what was said
uh in the midlands was different to what
was said here in scotland
they brought up the fact they thought
the manifesto was overloaded
and they didn't believe we could deliver
it all and in a number of places they
brought up anti-semitism so
there are a number of reasons and we
need to address all of them but we've
also i'm afraid
um got to face up to the fact that we've
lost four elections in a row
so we're not just analyzing what just
happened last december
we are also saying what's been happening
over a longer period
and whatever else you could challenge me
on brexit wasn't the cause of four
election losses for the labour party so
an honest assessment of the nature of
the task ahead is needed you obviously
travel the country a lot during the
election i certainly did too i spoke to
a lot of voters and brexit
as you know was brought up an awful lot
particularly with lead voters who
thought that the policy for a second
referendum
was overturning their votes when it came
out i mean you you were a big architect
of that because this came up actually
that position was adopted
firstly by the shadow cabinet and then
by you
i thought it was the right policy i
thought we should have gone on by the
way it actually said
which side we would be campaigning for
if there was a referendum do you still i
warned our party that if we looked
indecisive
we wouldn't look like we were leading on
this issue but of course it came up
i think our biggest problem in a sense
was that we didn't knock down that
phrase
get brexit done and we had a manifesto
with lots and lots of policies in it
boris johnson had three words and we
didn't knock it down you said that
you thought that was the right policy do
you still think it was the right policy
yes of course because what we were doing
was we were
we were fighting against a deal that we
thought would be very damaging for our
country
and it is important to remember that for
month after month after month and you
will have seen this
i was standing there putting forward
amendments to get a deal over the line
it was only when we were confronted with
theresa may's deal and then boris
johnson's deal
which i believe will be damaging for the
country that we even entertain the
question of putting it back
uh for people to uh agree or not agree
so
um we i don't know how many times i
pushed amendment for a customs union
and we got within three votes of it had
that succeeded
we would have left with a deal um so we
only moved on to the question of a
second referendum to to protect the
country
uh against a damaging brexit now when
you were talking about issues that
people raised
during the election campaign you also
mentioned anti-semitism yes
now of course you're a member a senior
member of the shadow cabinet what did
you personally do
to try and address the genuine concerns
that many had about anti-semitism in the
labour party i spoke out publicly on the
andrew mar show
on radio 4 on the pester show to say we
must have the international definition
of anti-semitism
to say that those who deny we've got a
problem are part of the problem
to say we need to change our respond to
interview questions what did you do well
i was making that case
the first thing was i was making those
arguments publicly the second thing was
i was making those points in the shadow
cabinet
we had a lot of discussion about
anti-semitism and a lot of challenge
went in in the shadow cabinet
on that now i've not been one to reveal
what's gone in the shadow cabinet
because i believe in collective
responsibility
but you shouldn't read into that that
there weren't very significant
challenges going on in the shadow
cabinet
so for example i was saying in order to
reassure us
we need to have periodic reports of the
shadow cabinet about how we're getting
on with disciplinary cases etc
in the end for me i said that the test
for our party
should now be whether those that have
left our party because of anti-semitism
feel comfortable to return to it and i
said that to louise elman when she
when she left our party and if i was
leader of labour party i would take
personal responsibility for this because
having run a big organization i know
that
if the person if the leader of the
organization has a line of sight
that changes the whole culture within
the organization
okay okay do you think jeremy corbyn had
a blind spot on it
i think jeremy should have been stronger
we should have been quicker on it
um but i don't want to point the finger
at one individual we failed on this
um i would take a different position as
leader of labor party i would make it my
responsibility to rebuild
trust with the jewish community i'd make
it my responsibility i'd say every
friday i need to see a report of how
we're getting on
because if the person at the top of the
organization says
i want to know what's going on every
friday or whatever it is
then in my experience from running a big
organization things change pretty
rapidly
a couple of other points i'm keen to get
in before the end of the interview we're
in glasgow
scotland um could you ever support
a second independence referendum in
scotland well
i don't support uh scotland leaving
the uk i think uh that that would be
damaging for scotland and damaging for
the uk um and so i think we should
be very very strong in making the case
for the united kingdom
i don't think the state i don't think
the status quo is working i do accept
that that's got to change but i don't
think that scotland leaving the uk is
the way forward can you rule out ever
supporting one well i've made
a different case which is for for
federalism a radical federalism and
that's what i believe in so
any manifesto under my leadership would
be putting that forward but i'll say
this just to
finish that answer that whatever
position in the end the labour party
takes it has to be done in agreement
with scottish labour
and i think there's been too much of a
gap between the leader of labour party
and scottish labor
lately and i want to close that gap and
make sure that we're working
together and that's why i've been up
here actually two or three weeks ago
having those discussions
and having further discussions today um
now at the first
leadership hustings yeah last month
we've rewind back seems
like it does it really does it's got a
long long way to go in the contest as
well
um you said i certainly won't be giving
interviews to the sun
during the course of this campaign why
not
well we were in liverpool does that
matter if you're in liverpool
oh it absolutely matters um the history
of hillsborough
and the sun's coverage of it absolutely
speaks for its for itself i think
everybody in liverpool still feels very
very strongly
about that but the sun has also i mean
there's been
within elements of the press elements of
the press i do defend
journalists and it's very important we
do but in elements of the press there's
been
vilification of labour leaders that's
gone on um
for many many years and jeremy corbyn
probably got it worse than any leader
this time and
when we went and knocked on doors and
people said they didn't like jeremy
corbyn
quite a bit of that was what had been
fed into them by
the press and we need we do need to
address this because
in the end if we lose any kind of
balance in the coverage of
politics we're on a slippery slope and
you know you can have an honest
discussion all you like about
politicians and politics
but once you're on that slippery slope
then we're losing touch with
with you know what actually matters i
mean to put the other
argument you know many of those voters
who labor lost at the last election
may well have been sun readers why don't
you want to talk to them well
i am talking to those voters i've spent
a lot of time
across the country talking to voters in
their communities
wherever they are having blunt and
gritty discussions
and that is one of the jobs of the
leader of labour party which is to
listen to people across the country
when you complained when number 10
excluded certain
media outlets from briefings i mean some
would say you're being
hypocritical by refusing there is a
massive difference
between an individual candidate saying
i'm not going to do an interview
with the sun and the prime minister
excluding
a section of the press from even getting
a briefing that there's miles of
difference between the two
okay okay now just finally you're the
last
uh man left in this race and the other
candidates are women now i spoke to
jess phillips who of course dropped out
of the race uh last month and
she said if you truly believe in women's
representation
sometimes passing the mic is the
greatest way to show
that you truly believe in something if
you ever consider passing the mic so
labour can have a female leader well
i've talked to the other candidates
about this because it comes up as you
can imagine
and i've said nobody in this is standing
because they're a man
or because there are women and the other
candidates agree with me we are all
honestly and genuinely putting forward
the case that we think is best for our
party our movement
and our country and uh we're doing that
in a very positive spirit by the way
we're
modeling uh the sort of unity that this
party absolutely needs we're not taking
lumps out of each other
and if we can model it during this
campaign and that's good for the labour
party but in the end our members will
decide having heard our arguments
but what i will say is i know that this
is not the job of one individual
and what i've been saying is don't
support me come alongside me because
this is going to have to be a team
effort
okay thank you very much for being on
the show thank you